a new study rasmussen poll is showing
that more Americans are officially as of
basically this week getting their news
from the internet rather than television
this doesn't surprise me as an addicted
tweeter that's pretty much where I get
all my info what about you guys are you
guys are you guys internet people are
you still old-school TV people where you
were you getting your name I am
constantly Mission Control which is
laptop and TV so I it's like for me
choosing you know between children like
I I'm in it deep in it yeah so I had to
only have one which one I mean if I had
to obviously I would choose the internet
because it's a more personal experience
and you you know it's more communicative
and whatever but you know Michael um I
only get my i get my news from Matt
Lauer on the tation when he's wearing
his glasses if he's not wearing his
glasses i will go to the internet
completely untrustworthy without glasses
right ah mine my new cell it is my
twitter feed that's what it is i mean i
try get all my news from just refresh it
that's my timeline that's how i figure
out what it's going on in the world the
days of me you know going home and
watching the nightly news you know it's
over it just doesn't have to me lately
it's like it's so catered towards old
people like if i happen to watch the CBS
nightly news it is it's almost like in
full sign language like they don't like
every so it's crazy every other story on
the nightly news always seems to be
about the AARP and what they're gonna do
and that old people are dying faster and
the death panels are coming so there
really is like an age divide what about
you Gloria where you get near town crier
I just go out and look for somebody to
yelm the street homeless person tell me
what's happening I uh I go to Facebook
honestly I'm the same way like I haven't
much I took a break from the news for a
little while I was stressing me out I
was head MSNBC like unconstitutional Ike
you've got to stop it like you're
becoming a lunatic and I said to my
mother if something important happens
let me know and then she called me she
said Al Roker [ __ ] himself and I said
that's the kind of fan thank you that
was important for letting me know that
yes I figure important things happen
people will let me know yeah well there
were some other numbers here that I
thought were really interesting six
percent of
that's six percent thinks that the
national media is trustworthy do you
guys think that can we trust the media
obviously we can trust us sitting here
right now do you trust I may be asked
right you know I don't trust that
statistic I think by default don't trust
the media because it's young it's to say
you trust the Metis you know it's you
seem uneducated to say that you should
always have a unhealthy distrusted of
the media I don't trust I don't believe
it I bet I bet ninety-five percent of
the people polled there will believe
most of what comes from the media not
believing in statistics and giving a
made-up statistic to back your stuff oh
no it's not made night I out in the
parking lot earlier i did a hot actual
pole that was quite a thing that's like
a real party downstairs yeah are you
guys surprised to know i'm gonna guess
not that four percent of republicans so
even less republicans think the media is
trustworthy ten percent of democrats so
that's that's pretty good one out of ten
democrats likes the media glory is
unimpressed no I i I'm just I mean who
isn't me everybody's the median every
cuz that's it you have the benefit of
like Twitter and Facebook we're all the
media now because we all were all
posting we're all like retweeting things
and taking little bits and pieces and
creating our own newsfeed it's called a
news feed literally yeah so it just
feels like if I'm on my couch um you
know ever since I moved to LA I'm like
panics about earthquakes and if I think
my couch is like actually on a fault
line like is it shakes all the time so
I'm constantly checking first thing to
do is go to Twitter and search
earthquake I do that probably three
times a day you know then follow on
Twitter that gives you real-time like I
know that is like a real-time earthquake
that would you not know if the
earthquake was really bad enough I
brochure no but if you if it's one of
those things like you said it's like oh
did I just have gas or did the earth
move yeah you know there was a fart yeah
things on Twitter yeah the shadow
building shakes what do you what do you
guys think about how we get all our news
cater to exactly what we like you know
what I mean if your left wing you follow
MSNBC and all the
I know we're and we're just endorsing
like our own stuff like preaching to the
choir it's very boutique now media is
very boutique like you go to your source
that gives you the kind of stuff that
you care about and that you're
interested in yes and who cares about
the rest of the world like if if you
shop at Target you're not going to go to
Fred Spiegel like you know I me like you
go to where you need to go people don't
want their viewpoints challenged in any
way so that's why Republicans are
watching Fox and everybody else is
watching everything else and then why I
listen to Rush Limbaugh all day bonobos
calm is the official outfitter of the
Ruben report enter code Ruben report for
twenty percent off your next purchase